one of the wisest things about young
children
is that they have no shame whatsoever
about
bursting into tears perhaps because they
have a more accurate and less
prideful sense of their place in the
world
they know they are extremely small
beings in a hostile and
unpredictable realm that they can't
control much of what's happening around
them
that their powers of understanding are
limited and that there is a great deal
to feel distressed
melancholy and confused about why not
then on a fairly regular basis
sometimes for only a few moments at a
time collapse into some
highly salary sobs at the sheer scale of
the sorrow
of being alive unfortunately
such wisdom tends to get lost as we age
we get taught to avoid being at all
costs that most apparently
repugnant and yet in fact deeply
philosophical of creatures
the cry baby we start to associate
maturity
with a suggestion of invulnerability and
competence
we imagine it may be sensible to imply
that we are unfailingly strong
and in command of what's going on but
this
is of course the height of danger and
bravado
realizing one can no longer cope is an
integral part of true
endurance we are in our essence and
should always strive to remain
crybabies that is people who intimately
remember their susceptibility to hurt
and grief
moments of losing courage belong to a
brave life
if we don't allow ourselves frequent
occasions to bend
we will be at great risk of one day
fatefully
snapping we labor under the
misapprehension that the only thing that
could justify
tears would be one clear and unambiguous
catastrophe but that's to forget how
many minuscule elements go wrong
every hour how much supposedly small
things can
impact us and how extremely heavy they
may end up feeling
in a very short time when the impulse to
cry strikes us
we should be grown up enough to consider
ceding to it
as we knew how to in the wisdom of our
fourth or fifth years
we should go to a quiet room put the
duvet over our heads
and give way to unrestrained torrents
at the horribleness of it all we easily
forget how much energy we normally have
to expend
fending off despair now at last we can
properly allow despondency to have its
way
no thought should be too dark anymore
we're obviously
no good everyone is evidently extremely
mean it's naturally far too much
our life is undoubtedly meaningless
and ruined if the session is to work we
need to touch the very bottom
and make ourselves at home there we need
to give our sense of catastrophe
its fullest claims then if we've
properly done our work
at some point in the misery one idea or
other however minor
will at last enter our minds and make a
tentative case for the other side
we'll remember that it would be quite
pleasant and possible
to have a very hot bath that someone
once stroked our hair kindly
that we have one and a half good friends
on the planet and an interesting book
still to read
and then we'll know that the worst of
the storm is
over despite our adult powers of
reasoning
the needs of childhood constantly thrum
within us
we're never far from craving to be held
and reassured
as we might have been decades ago by a
sympathetic
adult most likely a parent who made us
feel physically protected
kissed our forehead looked at us with
benevolence and tenderness
and perhaps said not very much other
than very quietly
of course to be in need as it were of
mummy is to risk ridicule especially
when we are a couple of meters tall
and in a position of responsibility yet
to understand and accept one's younger
longings
in fact belongs to the essence of
genuine adulthood
there is in truth no maturity without an
adequate negotiation with the infantile
and no such thing as a proper grown-up
who does
not frequently yearn to be comforted
like a toddler
in sensible households we should all
have signs a bit like the sort they have
in hotels
that we can hang on our doors and
announce to passers-by
that we're spending a few minutes inside
doing something essential to our
humanity
and inherently connected to our capacity
to live
like a grown-up that is sobbing
like a lost child
our emotional barometer is a tool that
can help us to more clearly explain our
moods
click the link on screen now to find out
more
you